Vice President Mike Pence delivering a
commencement speech at Indiana's Taylor
University I put my faith in Jesus
Christ is my personal Lord and Savior
and it's made all the difference in my
life I want to encourage you to go from
here and live it out because America
needs men and women of integrity and
faith now more than ever now most of the
schools nearly 500 graduates stayed for
the speech but dozens of grads and
faculty reportedly walked out before he
even started talking well here to react
is the host of the Michael Knowles show
Michael knows good morning sir what a
Michael good to see you how do you react
to what happened there listen the
students are often going to behave as
uneducated ignorant reckless that's
almost the definition of what a student
is the good news here is that the Taylor
University administration did not give
in to them that vice president Mike
Pence did not back down when you see
these groups on campuses the professors
the students the administrators we all
make fun of the snowflakes but all too
often it's the administration that is
giving in and that is hollowing out
liberal education we saw this at
Stanford the other day the
administrators there smeared and invited
speaker Andrew Klavan we saw this at
University of Missouri Kansas City when
I was physically assaulted and the
Chancellor blamed me for being invited
and gave in to the hecklers and the
censors there it's good on Taylor that
they're doing this we need to stand up
for that the problem is administrative
bloat and the way that we can fight that
is we as taxpayers and the legislators
can go in there cut those salaries and
get these useless deans of inclusion and
diversity and deputy deans and assistant
Dean's get them out of there and get
back to educating generations of
Americans yeah Michael it's amazing how
many titles there are when you go to
university there's like a job for
everything now but one thing you
mentioned good on Taylor University I
agree with you and they actually put a
statement out that I deeply appreciate
it it says quote we are deeply grateful
the president the vice president of the
United States would visit our campus
share with our graduating class and
their families and help us celebrate the
accomplishments of our class of 2019 so
I think what's important here is to pay
attention to the universities that don't
back down that don't cave to the mob and
the increasing number of universities
that are going to allow diverse
city of commencement speakers and
diversity of thought in those places and
say you know what we are University and
somewhere in here we have to acknowledge
and respect that this is supposed to be
a place where diversity of thought
thrives imagine the idea that a 22 year
old know nothing might be able to learn
something from the Vice President of the
United States that's the sort of
intellectual humility that our
educational institutions should be
instilling with students unfortunately
the rule from Yale all the way to
Stanford coast-to-coast is to give in to
the leftist mob even though they're
small and number they're very loud and
absolutely we need to cheer on Taylor
University and other schools like the
University of Chicago were Purdue under
president mitch Daniels who are standing
up for free speech and the free exchange
of thought on campus
well another guy who's giving freely his
thoughts is one of the presidential
candidates robert francis O'Rourke he
hit the reset he's trying to you know
reboot his campaign which means he's
doing more national interviews while he
was on with another network yesterday
this is what he said about Trump's
election we know from other secretaries
of state in other states in the Union
that their systems were breached we
don't know if vote tallies were changed
but but that alone should be cause for
concern
so he's insinuating that Trump actually
may not have legitimately won the
election I think bado accidentally
rebooted himself all the way back to
2016 is pushing the same ridiculous hoax
that we've heard for two years maybe he
could reboot himself back to that Texas
Senate race that he lost I think then he
might have a chance of getting this
nomination
yeah are you impressed at all with the
reboot clearly not the reboot is not
quite worked I think Joe Biden Pete
Buddha judge virtually every other of
one of the 23 candidates is eating
Vado's lunch